가능한 거죠. 오류를 낼 가능성을 줄일 수 있는 상황의 예시로, 우리의
목표가 가상의 수신자에게 단일 비트를 전달하는 것이고, 이를 위해 비트를
소위 이진 대칭 채널을 통해 전송할 수 있다고 가정해 봐요. 이 채널은 전송되는 각 비트를 어떤 확률로 독립적으로 뒤집어요.
확률 P로요. 확률 1 빼기 P로 수신자는 우리가 보내려는 비트를 받겠지만, 확률 P로
비트가 뒤집혀서 수신자는 우리가 보낸 것과 반대 값을 받아요. 그래서 반복
코드를 사용하지 않고 그냥 생각하는 비트를 채널을 통해 보내면, 수신자는 잘못된 비트를 받을 거예요.
확률 P로요. 반면에 먼저 3비트 반복 코드를 사용해 보내려는 비트를 인코딩한 다음
인코딩의 세 비트 각각을 채널을 통해 보내면, 각각이 확률 P로 뒤집혀요.
이제 비트 플립 가능성은 더 높아지는데, 하나가 아닌 세 비트가 뒤집힐 수 있으니까요.
하지만 최대 하나의 비트만 뒤집힌다면 수신자는 올바르게 디코딩할 수 있어요. 그래서 오류는
전송 중에 두 개 이상의 비트가 뒤집힐 때만 디코딩 후 발생하는데, 이게 발생하는 확률을 계산하는 건 어렵지 않아요.
확률은 3 곱하기 P의 제곱 빼기 2 곱하기 P의 세제곱이에요. P가 1/2보다 작은 경우
수신자가 잘못된 비트를 얻을 확률이 줄어들어요. 이 경우에도 오류 가능성은 있지만
코드가 그 가능성을 줄여줘요. 가능성을 더 줄이고 싶다면 다른
코드를 사용해서 그렇게 할 수 있어요. 인코딩된 비트가 세 번 이상 반복되는 반복 코드를 사용하는 것도 포함해서요.
P가 1/2보다 큰 경우에는 그런데 이 코드가 실제로
수신자가 잘못된 비트를 얻을 가능성을 높인다는 의미에서 상황을 더 나쁘게 만들어요. 그래서 그런 상황에서는 당연히 이 코드를 사용하지 않겠죠.
3비트 반복 코드는 고전 오류 정정 코드지만, qubit에 대한 오류로부터 보호하는 데도 사용하려면 어떻게 되는지 생각해볼 수 있어요.
그렇게 좋은 Quantum 오류 정정 코드는 아니에요. 보게 되겠지만 일부 오류는 정정할 수 있지만 다른 오류는 더 발생하기 쉽게 만들어요.
하지만 Shore 코드를 향한 첫 번째 단계예요. 그러니 qubit에서 어떻게 작동하는지 봐요. 먼저 명확히 하자면, 3비트 반복 코드가 qubit에 사용된다고 할 때
우리가 생각하는 건 화면에 표시된 것처럼 qubit의 인코딩이에요. 여기서 알파 0 더하기 베타 1은
알파 000 더하기 베타 111로 인코딩돼요. 즉 표준 기저 상태가
세 번 반복되는 거예요. 특히 이건 양자 상태를 세 번 반복하는 것과는 다른 거예요. 주어진
양자 상태 s를 s 텐서 s 텐서 s로 인코딩하는 것과는 달리, 그건 우리가
미지의 양자 상태 s에 대해 구현할 수 없는 인코딩이에요. 복제 불가 정리 때문에요. 반면에 우리가 얘기하는
인코딩은 매우 쉽게 구현돼요. 여기 두 개의 초기화된 작업 qubit와 두 개의
제어 NOT gate를 사용하는 아주 간단한 Quantum circuit이 있어요. 자, 이제 인코딩이 수행된 후
오류가 발생한다고 가정해 봐요. 특히 Pauli X 연산, 즉 비트 플립이 qubit 중 하나에서 발생한다고
가정해 봐요. 이 그림에서는 중간 qubit이에요. 물론 이게 발생할 수 있는 유일한 오류는 아니고
오류가 이 완벽한 유니터리 연산의 형태를 취한다는 아이디어에 반대할 수도 있어요. 하지만 강의 후반부에 다시 이 부분으로 돌아올 거예요. 지금은 그냥
예시로 생각해요. 결과 상태는 이래요. 각 K 내의 중간 비트가 뒤집혔다는 점만 빼면
원래 인코딩과 동일해요. 물론 우리는 상태의 수학적 표현을 통해 이걸 볼 수 있어요.
하지만 세 qubit만 있고 비트 플립이 발생했을 수 있다고 의심하지만 어떤 qubit에 영향을 미쳤는지 모른다고 가정해 봐요.
비트 플립이 발생했는지 알아내는 한 가지 방법은 표준 기저 측정을 수행하고 결과를 검사하는 거예요. 이 경우 우리는
알파와 베타에 따른 확률로 010 또는 101을 보게 될 거예요. 두 경우 모두 결론은
중간 비트가 뒤집혔다는 거예요. 하지만 불행히도 그것은 원래 양자 상태를 망가뜨려요. 그리고 이 상태는
우리에게 소중할 수 있어요. 결국 전체 목적이 이 양자 상태를 보호하는 거잖아요. 그래서 이건 좋은
선택지가 아니에요. 대신 우리가 할 수 있는 건 화면에 표시된 quantum circuit를 사용하는 거예요. 인코딩된 상태를
상위 세 qubit에 입력하는 거예요. 기본적으로 이 circuit가 하는 건 표준의 패리티를 계산하는 거예요.
상위 두 qubit에 대한 기저 상태뿐만 아니라 인코딩의 하위 두 qubit에 대해서도요. 이렇게 하면
비트 플립의 위치가 드러나요. 특히 이 경우 두 패리티 검사 모두에서 결과 1을 얻을 거예요.
그 정보로부터 중간 비트가 다른 두 비트와 다르다는 결론을 내릴 수 있어요. 그래서 그게 분명히
뒤집힌 거예요. 그리고 중요한 건 이게 상태 붕괴를 일으키지 않는다는 거예요. 이제 이 비트를 정정하려는 시도를 해볼 수 있어요.
그래서 결국 원래 상태를 디코딩하고 되찾을 수 있을 거예요. 정정 부분으로는
잠시 후에 돌아올 거예요. 하지만 먼저 비트 플립 오류의 다른 가능성들을 간단히 살펴봐요. 대신 비트 플립 오류가
하단 또는 왼쪽 qubit에서 발생했다면 아래에서 위로 읽어서 결과 10을 얻을 거예요.
그리고 다시 상태는 변하지 않아요. 만약 비트 플립이 상단 qubit에서 발생했다면 결과는
01이 될 거예요. 그리고 다시 상태는 변하지 않아요. 그리고 만약
비트 플립 오류가 전혀 없었다면 측정 결과는 00이고 다시 상태는 변하지 않아요.
이걸 표 형태로 요약해 볼게요. 최대 하나의 비트 플립으로 얻을 수 있는 각 가능한 상태를 나열하고, 측정
결과인 오류 정정 맥락에서 신드롬이라고 부르는 것과, 원래
인코딩을 되찾기 위해 해야 할 정정을 나열해요. 오류가 없었다면 신드롬은 00이고 상태를 고치기 위해 아무것도 할 필요가 없어요.
하단 또는 왼쪽 qubit에서 비트 플립이 발생했다면 신드롬은 10이고 적절한 정정은
하단 또는 왼쪽 qubit에 X gate를 적용하는 거예요. 다른 두 경우도
비슷해요. 그래서 신드롬을 기반으로 적절한 정정을 적용하면 네 가지 경우 모두에서 원래
인코딩을 확실히 복구할 수 있어요. 다시 한번, 최대 하나의 비트
플립 오류만 발생했을 가능성만 고려하고 있어요. 두 개나 세 개의 비트가 뒤집히면 제대로 작동하지 않고, 다른 오류의
가능성도 아직 고려하지 않았어요. 이제 양자 환경에서 다른 유형의 오류를 고려해 봐요. 비트
플립 오류는 우리가 걱정해야 할 유일한 오류가 아니에요. 예를 들어 위상 플립
오류, 줄여서 위상 플립도 걱정해야 해요. 이는 Z gate, 즉 Pauli Z로 표현돼요.